where is Stevo from I grew up in five  different countries if you can believe  it I was born in England moved to Brazil  when I was six months old moved to  Connecticut when I was four to Florida  when I was six to England when I was  nine to Canada when I was 12. back to  England when I was 13 then I really  started traveling is Stevo teeth real  well  those ones are really gone the rest of  them have fake stuff mounted on they're  there they just have crowns and veneers  is Stevo married I'm not married but I  am engaged and I wear this ring as a  sign of respect because let's face it  what's wrong with our society that only  women should indicate that they're taken  is the idea that men should just go and  do whatever they want now I'm taking